Now, TCP flows are synchronized, the dynamics of
the aggregate window as shown in the upper part of the graph, would have the
same dynamics as any individual flow. The quantities
on the Y axis here would simply be different. Specifically, the number
of pockets occupying the buffer would be the sum of all
of the TCP flows windows, rather than the
window of any individual flow. Now if there
are only a small number of flows in the network then these flows may tend to
stay synchronized, and the aggregate dynamics might mimic
the dynamics of any single flow as shown.
But as the network supports an increasingly large
number of flows, these individual TCP flows become de-synchronized.
So instead of all of the flows lining up with the saw tooth as shown in
the bottom part, individual flows might see peaks
at different times. As a result, instead of
seeing a huge sawtooth that's the sum of
a bunch of synchronized flows, the aggregate instead
might look quite a bit more smooth, as
a result of the individual flows being desynchronized.
And we can represent this sum, which
is the buffer occupancy, as a random variable.
At any given time, it's going to take a particular range of values. The range of
values that this buffer occupancy takes, can
actually be analyzed in terms of the central
limit theorem. The central limit theorem tells
us that the more variables that we have,
and, in this case the number of variables are the number of unique congestion
windows of flows that we have. The narrowerer the Gaussian will be. In this
case, the Gaussian is the fluctuation of the sum of
all of the congestion windows. In fact the width decreases as 1/
root N, where N is the number of unique, congestion windows of flows that
we have. And therefore, instead of the required buffering, needing to
be 2T times C. We can get away, with much less buffering.
In particular, 2 times C divided by the square root of
n. Where N, is the number of flows, passing through the router.